thank you for coming everyone there's
some amazing places that are showing up
we saw Iran and Portugal and where else
we see Seattle exotic Seattle we saw
South Africa we saw Alaska I've always
wanted to go to Alaska there's a bunch
of book clips here the SU book club the
why guys and why gals book club I love
all the book clubs because as you know
the whole reason we did this was that we
can do things together so it's nice that
everybody is forming a book club I'll
just wait another second or two to let
some more people come over from YouTube
to Instagram give him a second or two to
log on and all that good stuff I'll I'll
say that last last week was so inspiring
and fun I had such a good time as you
can see I shaved and I put a shirt on
the good news is I still remember how to
do buttons cuz it's been a while so
that's good and the reason we did this
book club is because it's been 10 years
since I start with why I came out and I
wanted to do a ten year anniversary
edition and go update it and sort of
make some edits things that I would have
said differently and I figured well if I
have to read it it might be fun to
invite people to come read it with me
which is why we started book club and
now that we're all sort of under
lockdown for for corona I figured why
not use this as an opportunity for
people to do something together to form
book clubs whether it's in their family
at home among their family at home or
with friends virtually to read a section
every week and discuss it as a book club
and then come on here and we can discuss
it together that so that was the whole
purpose of this purpose of this is that
we could do something together so thank
you to everyone who participated thank
you to everyone for all your questions I
thought what I would do is this was a
chock-a-block full section this is where
I first introduced the concept of the
Golden Circle explain the biology of it
and talk about sort of how the mechanics
of
the Golden Circle work although what I
might do to kick off today's book club
was just share a little bit about how I
came up with book book club how I came
up with the concept of the Golden Circle
so I I have a my career started in
marketing and I was always fascinated by
some marketing some advertising worked
and some didn't I worked at a big agency
where I could take the same clever team
and they would make stuff that worked
and stuff that didn't so it wasn't the
team and sometimes it was the same with
the client but there was always
marketing out there and when I grew up
it when my was coming of age in my
career
Apple was such a dominant force and
their their marketing was incredible and
why is it that their work was so good
because their agency produced bad work
as well so it wasn't just the agency and
so I would look at all of the marketing
and advertising that I admired and I
noticed that there was actually a
pattern that they always started with
what they believed at the top and the
product stuff came at the bottom the bad
advertising was the opposite so I
actually wrote down this pattern pretty
early on and I used to use it to explain
how marketing worked I was that a as an
event and you know you sit around a
table and you get seated next to
strangers and the person I was sitting
next to a woman by the name of Victoria
Hopper her dad I think it was her dad
was a neuroscientist and you know we
were talking and she started telling me
about the limbic brain in the neocortex
and the more I started to learn the more
interested I became I started doing some
basic research about the neocortex and a
little bit brain when I got home and
realized this little pattern that I had
written down to explain marketing wasn't
just marketing it was us it was why we
do what we do it explained the behavior
of people that I tripped over this and
then when I went through this dark
period in my own life which I've talked
about many times when I explained this I
had this little idea on the shelf that I
went to and realized that it was a
salvation for me because I knew what I
did and I knew how I did it but it
didn't know why so when I realized the
biology behind this I realized this was
more than just a nice idea and a nice
theory it was actually grounded the
tenets of biology and not only did it
help me but it helped explain so much of
what was going on and as I explained in
the section I called it the Golden
Circle
because I was inspired by the golden
ratio this magical ratio that sort of
exceeds to explain so many things and
shows up in so many places and I figured
that if this thing shows up in so many
places actually call it golden as well
so that's where where the whole thing
actually came from so let's I tell you
one of the fun things about reading this
book you know some of it I smile at how
relevant it is still is today so
relevant about how we're being
communicated at in these Korona times
and even how we communicate to each
other and how we're learning to reinvent
ourselves even we're trying to reinvent
our own organization as we're going
through these these weird times and it's
kind of wonderful I'm sort of getting
reference I'm actually learning about
stuff that I've forgotten about that
that's really helpful
I cringe at some of it because some of
it's a little dated and
some of the references I make like two
PDAs your personal digital assistant we
don't even use those anymore because we
all have smartphones so I recognizes a
group of people who are reading the book
who don't even know what I'm talking
about but still it's been a lot of fun
for me okay let's do your questions
because that's the whole point of this
and that's the fun okay let's have a
question let's take a look here I have a
question from Wayne Wayne uh how do you
know if your why is something you can
lead others with that's a great question
well Wayne if you've ever made a friend
then your why has relevance in the lives
of other people at the end of the day
you know wise are compatible with each
other and so why is the thing that it's
the thing we give to the world
it's the it's the service we offer it's
the value we have in our friends lives
or if you're a company it's the value
you haven't in your customers lives and
if they find value in that thing they
will want to be around you they feel a
tribal connection and so the good news
is if you're a human being your Y will
have relevance to others and if you have
a vision of a world that you want to
build others will follow you to help
build that so
you're why we'll always have relevance
to some other people not all other
people and and if you invite them to
come build something and you talk about
your why I talked about that actually in
this section which is you simply knowing
it and trusting your gut is no value to
anybody else the value of articulating
your why and being able to communicate
your why is the thing that makes you
able to lead with your why good question
Wayne
okay let's Fiona at the Brighton world
book club yes if you're not in a
position of authority for the
organization but you see a wife or the
organization what do you do well that's
a tricky one the very often there's in
organizations all organizations that
sort of make anything of themselves
probably started with a why they may not
the leaders may not have properly
articulated it and it may have been
organic and the personalities of the
leaders and usually those organizations
they tend to be weak in the sense that
even if they're very successful if the
leader leaves then things start to get
weird and go sideways because it was
held by the leader not necessarily
acculturated into the company and
sometimes we can see things that the
leader can't see if it's a good leader
and they're open-minded then you go to
them and ask can I help we can go
through a process to articulate the why
one of the things that I found even
amongst extremely successful leaders and
entrepreneurs is they have this false
belief that because it's clear to them
that it's clear to everybody but it's
not and so it requires a good
relationship to be able to go up to them
and say hey listen I know you think it's
clear for everybody but it's not so let
us take you through the process to
uncover your why so we know the why for
our own organization so if you have a
good leader who's open minded to that
they'll go through the process and I've
done that with multiple leaders where
they still even going through the
process didn't think they needed to do
this but their team asked them to do it
and they did it willingly for the good
of their team if there's a leader who
says no we were crystal clear on what it
is
then the best thing you can do is just
be the leader you wish you had you can
lead for the people around you we cannot
control that which we cannot control so
hopefully you have a good relationship
with that leader
let's they've got a nice question here
from Edmond oh then I'm gonna say this
is a good one I like this one I'll get
to Edmonds in a second so uh oh I lost
it here it is from Oh Scarlett uh 84
Oscar lunar Oh Oscar Luna oh there we go
it's off my word are we changing the way
we try to fit or belong to a certain
group in this kovat 19 era that's such a
good question nothing really changes the
way in which we try and fit what's what
I really like about this coded thing is
that the silly things that we used to
use to connect us to other people
superficial things seem to have gone by
the wayside this is one of the great
things about hardship and crisis is a
lot of the superficial stuff falls to
the wayside because we're all going
through the same thing there's a shared
suffering and so people who we may not
have had a connection with before we now
actually have connections with I'm in
California and everybody's waiting to
each other
when we're going out for a walk or when
somebody drives past it's kind of weird
like nobody used to wave to anybody ever
again there's a shared camaraderie and
even now think about how we're so
connected around the world it doesn't
matter if our nation's or historically
friends or allies or not we feel very
connected to each other we have much
more of a connection much more of a
related story before our related stories
were so different and now we're reminded
that we're human and we're all
susceptible to the whims of Mother
Nature
so I think crisis and code 19 has
actually been good for us
good for us as a people the question is
will it last once this is all over I
really hope that we have to work hard at
that
okay back to Edmunds question Edmund
asked since the publishing of this book
in 2009 lots has changed in the tech
industry especially for Apple you use
Apple and your book is an example of a
company that understands there why do
you feel that it is still the case today
or have their last their why that's such
a good question it takes a long time for
a large corporation to
completely abandon their why but you
know if we're honest there are
definitely cracks on the armor
Apple used to be an organization that
ignored Wall Street and never paid
dividends for example and now it does
pay dividends and the company seems to
be more preoccupied than it used to be
with the short term financial standing
and the stock price that's relatively
new even in the terms of innovation
Apple seems to be playing catch-up with
a lot of companies a lot of products and
you know that Apple wasn't always the
first to come out with something but it
would sometimes do something better you
know I hate to say this the home pod is
not a great product the speaker is
amazing if you just use it as a speaker
it's unbelievable but as a comparator to
do Google home or to Alexa it's it's it
sucks
I never I've never said that about an
Apple product in the past it's pretty
but it sucks so you know it's not the
same as it used to be and we can we can
make certain assesses based on how we
experience the product experience their
advertising and experience their stuff
you know I don't think it's completely
abandoned there cause not at all
I still could I still think there's
idealism there I still think Apple
stands for the individual their stance
on privacy for example is very much
power to the individual just like they
always believed in power to the
individual the question is are they
obsessed with their cause as they used
to be and are they still talking about
power to the individual in the halls of
Apple I don't know okay Olivia okay
Chris Kevon asked if you're graduating
college how to use your why when you
launch yourself into this new world
especially into a very uncertain future
well here's the good news Chris the
future is always uncertain we just
a reminded of it right now this is one
of the downsides of good times which is
we falsely believe that there will
always be good and we don't prepare for
disasters like this one so the future is
always uncertain I think that there's
great opportunity to be had in times
like this it's a time for great
reinvention we become I actually think I
talked about this in the chapter good
question Chris references the section we
just read in one of the sections we read
I talked about how going the
organizations that define themselves by
what they do and I think I used Dell as
an example really struggle to reinvent
themselves and I think I use the airline
example as well simply copying how other
people do things or how other
organizations do things simply to appear
that you are doing something different
doesn't really work and to really the
organizations that have not only have
the ability to go and do different
things but to reinvent themselves really
have a fundamental understanding of
their why's same is true for human
beings same is true for individuals the
clearer the understanding of our Y the
more opportunity you will find out there
so let's take me for example right so
most of my living I make standing on
stages at giving public speeches that's
kind of a lot of what I do
well that dried up super quick so what
if I was defining myself by what I do as
an author and a speaker then I would
freak out I would start writing more
books which I couldn't write back
quickly and I would be looking for ways
simply to give speeches online but
that's not reinvention that's not taking
advantage of the situation to bring my Y
to life so that's what we've done as an
organization we've gone back to wire my
Y to inspire people to do the things
that inspire them so together each of us
can change our world for the better and
we're looking for new and creative ways
to do that you're going to start seeing
some of it coming out live in in the
next week or so we're gonna be offering
all kinds of new classes and webinars
and things some hosted by me some not
hosted by me because we're finding new
ways to bring the cause to life so going
back to your question Chris as a college
graduate
don't worry about what you're gonna do
worry about why you're setting out into
the journey in the first place and
remember your first job is not gonna be
your last job and your first job doesn't
have to be your best job it's the
journey it's about refining and learning
what you're good at learning where your
skills lie and the question is is where
should you start your journey and
appreciate each step of the journey but
it's an amazing opportunity for a young
person now believe it or not because you
have an opportunity to completely
reinvent how you show up in the world
rather than follow the set paths that
were set for us in conventional times
here's one I'm gonna take a live one
let's take a Lyman oh my god there's so
many so much love thank you everyone
hello from Morocco I went to Marrakesh I
love it there went to Marrakesh twice
actually best orange juice I ever had in
my life
okay so Janina from valiance future asks
thank you for starting this book club
great idea thank you
Janina we enjoyed the first episode a
lot especially the questions read by
your daughter my niece our company we
have great why' taking care of a better
climate yet it is not even known
throughout the organization 13,000
people how do you manage to anchor it to
a large to larger organizations so
taking care of a better climate I would
let me push you there a little bit the
why probably doesn't have to do with the
climate the manner in which you're
bringing the why to life has to do with
the climate why almost always has to do
with human beings and if climate worried
a challenge in our lives right now
you're why would be the same you'd be
bringing it to life in a new way but
that's not the question you're asking
the question is asking is how do you
bring it to life in a large organization
well just like bringing it to life in
the pot to the public you have to talk
about it the leaders have to start
meetings with it but leader you have to
put it on your website the leaders have
to give speeches to the team about it
you need to give awards that recognize
people who advance the cause you need to
build it into the incentive structure
you need to talk about it obsessively to
the point where people make fun of you
and say we know we know you know right
what you find is great leaders
they're constantly talking about the
same themes over and over and over again
go to the companies we love you know go
to sweet green they talk about
sustainability and and and health and
local and local farming obsessively they
took and it's written in the walls if
their office I'm a great fan of taking
advantage of the walls in your office
walk through the hallways look look in
stairwells usually they're empty put big
words remind people
I visited a dance company in London
called rum bear and there they're wise
all about push yourself and we walk
through the the stairwell because
sometimes the elevator takes too long so
we took the stairs and guess what the
stairwell was barren bare nothing in
there what a missed opportunity not
anymore now on one floor and huge
letters it says push on the next level
that says yourself in big big letters it
reminds everybody who walks up and down
the stairs so in an office you can paint
it you can put it everywhere if you
visit Southwest Airlines headquarters in
Dallas they have a company store the
company's store is actually in the
cafeteria it's in the company cafeteria
what's the company's store called it's
called the freedom shop in other words
right there in the cafeteria reminds
everybody why they come to work freedom
so take advantage of the office walls
and make sure you communicate it loudly
and often ok
how somebody lost it here we go this is
Cala
sorry keeps popping up how can we
clearly understand our why there are
many ways to find your why actually in
about a week in the next few days to a
week we will actually be doing a little
program called jumpstart your why where
we're gonna take a group of people
through a 90 minute to 120 minute
exercise where you can come and
jumpstart your why so stay tuned for
that we'll announce that that's one way
to do it I'll share another way with you
I have a little thing called the friends
exercise which you can do to get
yourself in the ballpark
find a friend you
who loves you do not do this with a
family member do not do this with a
spouse that relationship is too close
find a friend the friend who you could
call at 3 o'clock in the morning and you
know they would take the call or that
they could call you and you would always
take the call in the matter what friends
you love and ask them this question why
are we friends they're gonna look at you
like you're crazy what do you mean why
are we friends now ironically finding
your why you don't actually ask the
question why because it's an emotional
question and it elicits emotional
answers have you ever had it when you're
at work and somebody says why did you do
it that way sort of you take offense
like they're challenging you even if
that's not how they meant it so as soon
as your friend asked what are you
talking about why you asking me this you
actually then start asking what come on
you say to your friend what is it about
me that I know that you would be there
for me no matter what and they'll hema
know how they'll struggle to answer the
question as we read in the last section
not because they don't know why they're
love you it's because the part of the
brain that controls the feeling of love
doesn't control language the limbic
brain doesn't control language they will
struggle to put into words of why they
love you why you're their friend so
they'll start rationalizing just what we
read in this last chapter they'll start
rationalizing I don't know you're funny
you're loyal you've always been there
for me you have to play devil's advocate
don't help them don't let anybody else
help them but you play devil's advocate
you say well that's the definition of a
friend you can say that about anybody
what specifically magical words
specifically what specifically is it
about me that I know that you would be
there for me no matter what tell hem
Aloha they'll get frustrated you'll keep
playing devil's advocate you'll keep
saying things like well that's us the
definition of the best friend and
eventually they'll give up and
eventually they'll start describing
themselves and what my friend said to me
is I don't know Simon all I know is I
can just sit in the room with you I
don't even have to talk to you and I
feel inspired and I got goose bumps in
fact I'm getting them right now in other
words what they finally articulate is
the value you have in their lives by
talking about yourself and you will have
some sort of an emotional reaction
you'll get goose bumps or you are well
up something will happen
you'll you'll emotionally respond to
limbic brain you'll emotionally respond
to the word they say because the things
we give to the world is the value our
friends have for us so if you were to do
this with multiple friends you love you
will get exactly the same answer if not
very very close because the value we
have is our Y so that's a fun way to
find your wife won't give you the exact
words but it'll put you in the ballpark
it's kind of a it's kind of fun we just
have a drinking problem
goal December do you think a personal
wine business
Goldust is a personal why the same as a
business wipe yes
why is basically an origin story it's
where we come from so for an individual
it's the sum total of how we were raised
the lessons we learned from our parents
from our friends from the experiences we
had growing up our Y is fully formed
probably by our mid to late teens we are
who we are and it never changes for the
rest of our lives a company if there's a
founder or small group of founders the
company takes the Y of their founder
virgin is Richard Branson they share why
he built the company in His image just
because it got big doesn't mean it
changes the goal is to keep it clear so
it can stay clear as it gets big for too
many organizations when they start
having success they forget about the why
and become obsessed with the what they
become obsessed with the results and
actually forget about the origin story
but yes it's basically the same process
because what is a company just a group
of people that's all it is
it's a corporate structure but
fundamentally it's a group of people who
come together it's a tribe and so how we
define the Y of a tribe if it's a person
or a small group of people who says I'm
starting my own tribe and it's based on
some sort of values and vision well
guess what it's the exact same thing now
can you break it in a company of course
you can but can we forget it as
individuals absolutely we can be out of
balance we can suffer stress and
depression sometimes when we forget our
Y our friends will say to us it's like I
don't know who you are anymore
so both are the same process to find
them and both have to work very very
hard to maintain them which is why I
often interchangeably talk about
individuals or organizations it's the
same thing it's just the difference of
scale should we do one more okay yeah
yeah one more live question yeah go
ahead Oh Warren from England wants to
who inspires me and why thank you why
that's a good question you know there
are many people who inspire me who
you've never heard of them I have some
very dear friends people some of them I
wrote about in my books that I've become
friends with and they become mentors I
wrote about a general Laurie Robinson
and start with why we haven't got to
that chapter yet but we'll get there
amazing human being I've known her since
I wrote this book and she's become a
dear friend and mentor it totally
inspires me Lieutenant General George
Flynn from the Marine Corps I met him in
the course of writing leaders eat last
he's become a dear friend and mentor
Johnny Bravo who I wrote about and
leaders eat less dear friend and mentor
Bob Chapman these people inspire me
beyond beyond beyond so very often the
people that I write about have inspired
me because I wrote about them and I and
I have I have a lot of dear friends and
who do that for me okay we have let me
take one trip so I take one for the okay
I'm gonna take one from Marcus yeah
Marcus Michele in the rest of the read
to lead members group of leaders from
the from Walt Disney World hi Walt
Disney World I hope you're still doing
Disney like things from home singing in
performing and all that good stuff in
the ten years since start with Y came
out have you seen any companies or
public figures embrace the idea starting
with Y in the Golden Circle and really
changed the way that they operated and
made an impact in the world
any leader or company you would consider
referencing in the anniversary edition
of start with y thanks again hope you're
staying safe and healthy Thank You same
to you yes a lot of younger companies
have really embraced it
I mentioned sweet green before Airbnb
Clif Bar those are companies that I have
learned over the years I didn't know
this that had found my work and used
as the basis to help them understand
their own companies which is so
inspiring for me to discover those
things the cool ones are when people
actually make changes in their
organizations Bob Chapman the way I met
Bob Chapman who I wrote about
extensively and leaders eat last the
founder not the founder but the CEO of
barry-wehmiller he saw my TED talk about
start with Y and basically came to me
and said I I built this company based on
this idea you know I
he realized he was doing it
simultaneously by accident and I put
words to what he had done and and we met
became friends but that's such a great
question to reach out to the people who
who did actually make profound changes
based on the work and thank them and use
them as an example that's a great idea
Stephanie Wilson Simon what is your
message to all the paramedics EMT
doctors and nurses right now there why
is clear and evident but how do they
keep going
yeah to all the paramedics and doctors
and and medical professionals on the
front line there why is clear it's why
they keep going to work every day and we
are immensely grateful what would I say
to them take care of each other
I mean it seems self-evident but a lot
of forget I've seen some of the that
I've seen some messages that have been
coming from frontline medical
professionals and some of it has been
really gun wrenching the stress and the
tempo I mean if you're an ER doc or an
ER nurse for example you're used to gore
and blood and guts and and tragedy but
not at this this constant tempo this
constant tempo I read a article this
morning that a that a paramedic in New
York City they're responding to 1,500
calls a day or something crazy because
regular medical stuff is happening as
well so one of the things I did is I
actually reached out to some friends in
the military some combat medics Canne de
combat docs and I asked them for advice
so we're actually gonna go live on
Monday and so if you are a medic if you
are a doctor or a nurse
please submit your questions and I'm
gonna ask these combat medics live on
Monday for some advice but most
important thing is is mental health
managing energy and and being tough as
I've learned from these combat medics is
not the right thing to do like putting
on a brave face every day like you have
to have emotions and it's really healthy
to to go not by yourself but go with
someone and have a cry have a vent have
a scream have a yell you know get that
stress out it's really important to
manage the energy and manage the stress
along the way because if we
compartmentalize that they taught me if
we only do is compartmentalize when
everything goes back to normal that's
all gonna come flooding out so we'll
talk more about it with people who've
actually gone through something close to
this experience on Monday such a hard
question such a good question and again
thank you thank you to all of you who
keep volunteering to go to the frontline
every morning Adam brown from Alabama
and a brown from Alabama asks how would
you explain the Golden Circle
communication technique to young
officers that are trying to communicate
the why and how that connects to what
their Airmen sailors soldiers and
Marines are doing and does that differs
from private companies so in the
military and this is a military question
obviously very often they are our armed
services sometimes actually forget their
own why also they define themselves by
their sphere of operation right the Air
Force has historically said we fly
planes something Navy says well we we
drive ships and the army says well we're
infantry and the Marine says we're
infantry but they all have some kind of
boat and they all have some kind of
plane and they have the wholesome kind
of ground troops in other words they
actually kind of do what everybody else
does at different scales obviously what
defines the uniformed services is their
cultures an airman a soldier marine and
a sailor are different people who have
joined different tribes and somebody
who's struggling in the army may
actually succeed in the airforce or
somebody who's thriving in the Navy may
actually struggle in the Marine Corps
the different cultures and I think the
Marines do the best job of defining
themselves by their culture it's very
very people focused and depending on the
leaders in each of those forces but
that's really the opportunity is to
define the value based on the culture
for example the Air Force is not just a
bunch of folks who fly planes it's a
group of people who are trying to find a
better way of doing things if every
Marine is a rifleman every airman is an
innovator it's a cultural thing I can
talk about that for a long time so we'll
go into the next question yes hello from
South Africa ayran yes how do you know
your wife is going fuzzy and happy
people losing their wife how do you know
if your why is going fuzzy and how do
you keep your Y clear at all times
so think of a Y kind of like being
healthy right like how do you know when
you're unhealthy sometimes you have to
like be a little unhealthy for a while
before you start to feel or recognize it
it's kind of the same with your Y when
you abandon it or forget about it
sometimes it takes a few steps before
you start to see it stress usually goes
up difficult decisions sometimes get
more difficult joy of work goes away
goes downward and sometimes even
relationships will struggle we talked a
while ago sometimes people say it's like
I don't know who you are anymore those
are clear signs that the Y has gone a
little fuzzy so the question is how do
you get it back well there's many many
ways one it's kind of like a 12-step
program no number one you have to admit
you have a problem
number one you have to admit I think
it's gone a little fuzzy and you have to
take accountability and responsibility
for that you have to go back to your go
back to your roots go back to what your
Y is where you where you know that you
come from and who you are take
accountability go to those people and
say I've been off my game
my why's gone fuzzy I'm really sorry I'm
working at it and ask for help none of
us are strong enough to do this stuff by
ourselves now how do we guard against it
going fuzzy I surround myself with
symbols
as often as I can to remind me of my why
I'm human I forget it I become sometimes
stuck in the weeds I become distracted
by the details sometimes and I forget
the bigger picture we all do and so the
color orange for me is something I chose
to remind me of my why it's optimistic
you'll see the color orange on my
website you'll see it on stuff we sell
you'll see it on on PDFs I have orange
belts I have orange I have an orange on
my watch and you'll see I love orange
and it's a reminder to me but I don't do
if at the outside world it's for me also
pictures of people who remind you of
your why so Martin Luther King was on
the on my desktop of my computer for
many many years as a reminder of my why
I had quotes that I printed out on with
a label maker and stuck them all over
the place to remind me of my why and on
my computer I stick little labels that
says remember why you do what you do or
inspire someone I write the word inspire
someone everywhere so sometimes we have
to take accountability surround
ourselves it's like the answer I gave a
moment ago about an office take
advantage of all the blank space to
remind yourself and pay attention if
you're unhealthy if things have gone out
of balance hi Sarah sparkles good to see
you
okay let's do another question yes okay
the question was how do you move forward
if you're an introvert when you're why
demands that you're an extrovert okay
why would never demand that you be an
extrovert your job may demand that you
be an extrovert what you do may demand
that you be an extrovert but you're why
nothing to do with it you're why is a
belief set it's where your values
emanate from right it's it's how you
view the world it's how you approach the
world I'm an introvert my job requires
that I find energy to be a little more
extroverted if I had my choice I would
always be behind the scenes I am much
happier and in my happy zone behind the
scenes like this whole stay at home
order for for kovat it's like I've been
preparing my whole life for this it's
been it's like staying at home is just
fine and so for people who are naturally
and let's be clear and what we mean by
introvert and extrovert I like Susan
Cain's definition the author of the book
quiet it's not about how big your
personality is about how friendly you
are that it's not about how socially
awkward you are
I know socially awkward extroverts and I
know very social introverts it's nothing
to do with it it's about energy that
introverts wake up in the morning with
five coins and every social interaction
they have they spend a coin and by the
end of the day they feel depleted
extroverts wake up in the morning with
no coins and every social interaction
they have they get a coin and by the end
they feel rich like my extrovert friends
like when we go to a party at the end of
the party they want to keep going out
because they have all this energy from
the party me I want to leave early and
go home because I'm exhausted being
social this doing this right now all
this energy that I'm gonna be exhausted
in about 10 or 15 minutes because I have
to call upon this energy now how do I
call upon this energy I go to my why I
love doing this it's a joy for me to
share what I believe with other people
who believe what I believe we are the
army we're the ones building this world
together a world in which the vast
majority wake up every single morning
inspired feel safe no matter where they
are and and feel fulfilled at the end of
the day that is the world we're building
so for me this is an honor and a joy to
do it's for me it's worth the spend
spending the energy worth spending those
those coins I love that question okay
how do you separate why from ego whoo
that's a good question so why is is
knowing where you come from and ego is
is is I guess your self opinion right
and I think ego in itself is not a good
thing or a bad thing it's a nothing it's
just a thing I think when we talk about
the difference between healthy ego an
unhealthy ego a healthy ego is thinking
that you're good an unhealthy ego is
thinking that you're better than others
so I know some remarkable people with
huge egos I mean they think they're good
they know they're good they know there's
mark but if you come up to them and say
hey I have an idea they lean in and say
let's hear it they're open-minded to the
ideas of others they don't think they
have every answer and they understand
that one person can't have all the
answers so I think healthy ego is
knowing you're good unhealthy ego is
thinking you're better than others what
do we have here here's Andrew Beach from
the party of five book club
hi party of five book club I'm assuming
because there's five of you what are the
best ways for taking an organizational Y
and making it accessible to staff so one
of the this this is kind of what we
touched upon in this last section in the
book which I like which is you can have
a sense of your Y it can be in your gut
and to make it accessible to your staff
you have to find words that that connect
with people it's it's it's you know
Martin Luther King wasn't the first
person who suffered in a pre-civil
Rights America he wasn't the only great
orator of the day but he he found words
to put into language what so many of us
felt that we went that that's what I've
been trying to say and and usually
that's the that the art and skill of
great communication is finding the words
that that capture the feelings that
other people also have I think this is
the reason that my work has has has has
spread I hear this all the time from
people you put into words they tell me
they put in toward something I've been
trying to say for years and I think
that's what you have to do in your
organization you have to put into words
how other people feel about coming to
work why do they love coming to work
well that's that's the job of putting it
into Y and again there's a process to go
through that which is reasonably
efficient let's take a look Nadine asks
can there be an overdoing of the Y like
a cult status or something does it then
come rather manipulative rather than
inspiring so that all depends how the
leaders what with what are the leaders
in service to their people or the
leaders in service
themselves cult-like you can accuse any
strong organization with any strong
culture being cult-like the Marine Corps
has cult-like Apple computers for many
years cult-like the organization's with
a clear sense of shared values can
become cult-like now if it actually
becomes a cult it's because the leader
the leader thinks that puts themselves
first the leader is putting their
interest serves and is using everybody
else to benefit their their needs and
goals in in truly great leaders truly
great leaders see themselves in service
to the people and and the why can extend
beyond them for years to come so it they
sometimes may look the same but they're
definitely not the same it depends on
the motivation of the leaders and how
they choose to manipulate people with
that set of beliefs to get what they
want for themselves that here's one
these are such good questions Mahalo
Jeff asked what is the relationship
between intuition and our why so so the
why exists deep in that limbic brain
that part of the brain that controls our
feelings and our behavior but not
language and so we talk about gut
decisions or following your heart
you're not actually following your heart
your whole heart's a muscle that just
pumps blood it doesn't direct behavior
ever unless it hurts and you die and you
have heartbreak these are emotional
things we talk about oh it breaks my
heart no it doesn't it just hurts
emotionally intuition is the same thing
having intuition is having a sense of
something and when you know your why I
think it enhances intuition because what
the why is is the root of the intuition
and so when I go for example when I know
my why and it's front and center and I
keep it front and center the question
was asked some time ago what if you
forget it I sometimes do forget it when
I go into meetings and sometimes my
intuition must guides me because I start
focusing on the things they're telling
me I take bad advice
and trusting my gut trusting my
intuition is when I remind myself why I
do what I do and this is more important
than anything else and if I take a
different path I do so knowingly and I
know the costs of doing so
so intuition is one of those things it's
and I think the more we practice
starting with why the more we practice
leading with why the more we practice
making decisions with why the stronger
our intuition becomes good question we
started a little late so if you're free
this Saturday you know we'll go a little
longer if you like Livia Mikado and Neil
Humber yes how do you help everyone in
your organization to find their why as
we said before there's a process I've
tried to help people find their way
as many ways as I can
I told you about the friends exercise
you can everybody can do that it's super
easy I wrote a book called finder why
because for eight years people complain
that I wrote start with why and didn't
write how to find your way and the in
that book so we wrote find your why and
remember when I wrote start with why
this whole concept of why wasn't the
thing so it would have been too
complicated I realized it when I was
writing it would have been too much in
one book so eight years later I start
with why I wrote find your why so you
can go through the workbook that
workbook has both individual why
discovery process and group why
discovery process and as I told you
because we can't go into companies and
help them find their why anymore we kind
of help people in person find their why
anymore we're doing the jump start your
why workshop which we'll announce in in
a few days or a week at the most but
there's there's we've tried over the
years to produce many many ways I invite
you to go to our website Simon Singh
Kham there's some free downloads that
you can check out there the friends
exercise is a free download free pdf go
check it out and by the way when we do
this jump start your why it's going to
be a page you can model so you can
whatever you like so we want to try and
make this as accessible as possible to
as many people as possible I love that
the question was how does imposter
syndrome factor into defining your Y so
the clearer the Y is I think that you're
less susceptible to imposter syndrome
quite frankly because imposter syndrome
I don't think has anything to do with
your Y imposter syndrome is sort of
wondering whether you have any role to
play here I mean it's very often that
I'll find myself in meetings or meeting
people where I'm saying things and I'm
like why are they taking advice from me
like what's the heck do I know
but I'm still I still believe in the
stuff that I'm saying I I just am
surprised every time that other people
are interested is that imposter syndrome
I don't know but I think one of the
things that I discovered when the why
when my Y became clear is that it gives
you this sort of this really caught this
sort of calm confidence like it's not
the kind of confidence that's bombast
and beating your chest but it's it's a
quiet calm so sometimes in situations
where it's not going well
you know I should have shrugged my
shoulders and say okay this didn't work
I'll try it next time
so the whole imposter syndrome thing I
think I think you're less susceptible to
it if you're in the practice of starting
with Y and and using your Y as often as
possible one of the things that I do is
I don't I mind people when I come into
meetings I don't have the answer I don't
think I'm right I offer a perspective
and so I because I I set the I set the
expectation I don't feel like an
impostor with you know things that I'm
saying cuz I don't think I'm right and
think I'm offering a perspective so I
think I hedge against the imposter
syndrome because I'm not presenting
myself as some sort of expert but rather
just a student on a journey
thank you for all the nice comments
Thank You Martha
and Marcus and drones should we do a
couple more questions how do I have any
more here jewels golden yes the Wildey
things book club I know what that means
but I like the sound of it the wild
ebook things is the right one but their
house so the why oak oh that's a good
question how do you deal with a leader
whether Y is good and focused but their
house are not good for the employees
okay so remember the the the magic of
the Golden Circle is that no one piece
is more important than any other I don't
think the Y is more important than how
or what it's just the piece that's most
often neglected or forgotten which is
why I talk about it because everybody
knows what we know we have to do things
and make stuff and have a job and have
skills and some people know that you
have to like distinguish yourself from
everybody else like those things are not
new it's the Y that gets so often
forgotten but if any one of those pieces
is missing you are out of balance so the
fact that the Y is stronger this
organization are in this leader but the
house they don't follow a set of clear
values then they're out of balance the
golden circle is out of balance and
that's where they have to work by the
way you can have a super strong Y and
super strong house but if you don't
produce anything that helps bring it to
life and what you're doing is you know
doing whatever job you can find and like
not paying attention to finding a tribe
or finding a company where you feel like
you belong then your Y can be crystal
clear your values can be crystal clear
and you're gonna be struggling and feel
stress choose you're in a place doing
something that isn't where you should be
so hey believe it or not they're not off
the hook each piece of the Golden Circle
must be in balance for that calm
confidence for that for that focus for
that joy for that fulfillment for that
inspiration each piece has to be there
no one piece is more important than the
other
here and I like this one what's more
important for you why or vision
thank you and done that disappeared
idol I lusted it wait away what's more
important why or vision they're equally
is important they're different things so
why comes from the past remember it's an
origin story it's where we come from and
to discover your why you look backwards
in your life we look for patterns across
our life when things were naturally
going extremely well we look for
patterns we can identify that pattern
that is our why it's the thing that we
give to the world it comes from the past
it is the foundation of who we are
vision is where we're going it's about
the future it's about imagination it's
not based on something objective vision
is entirely subjective your why is
objective you have one it never changes
for your whole life your vision is
subjective you can pick any vision you
want it's the world you're trying to
build preferably it's good to stick to
one vision tweak it every now and then
because otherwise you're all over the
place but you can have more than you can
only have one why and everybody has one
you can have multiple visions you can
have one for your family one for your
company you can have one for your
community you can have multiple visions
you can apply them differently so I like
to talk about vision as a just cause
mainly because there's no standard
definition of vision and so many
organizations and individuals like my
vision is to be a millionaire my vision
is to I mean that's not a vision that's
just a goal that's why I call it a just
cause so for me vision is about just
cause a cause so just that we would
willingly sacrifice in order to help
advance this cause so think of it like a
house oh why is the foundation of the
house once you build a foundation it's
there it's solid it's what gives the
organization or you or our lives
structure but you don't change the
foundation that's it now you can have a
vision of the house you want to build of
the life you want to lead or the company
you want to build and you build on the
foundation so there's basic structure
that's gonna remain the same but you can
change the shutters you can add floors
you can expand you can expand you can
redecorate so vision is where the house
is going why is where the house is
coming from where it's built upon we'll
do one or two more and then I'll let you
go about your day and for some of you
go back to bed yeah thank you very much
for staying up I feel so bad for the
folks who were on YouTube I'm looking at
some of the comments somebody wrote is
it still over and I get the timezone
wrong I also feel so bad we will post
this I will save this and post this
we'll post this on YouTube for anyone
who missed it if you have friends who
wanted to be here and couldn't please
let them know we will put it up and if
believe it or not I have YouTube in the
background it's still telling me that
it's going live an hour later so
something's wrong there anyway we
figured it out so thank you everyone for
being patient meeting me here hello from
Germany yes so if my white doesn't match
the why of my colleagues yeah then one
of two things is happening they're
assuming that everybody is clear on
their why and operating in balance but
there why that means you probably don't
get along so for example if your Y
doesn't match the Y of your friends you
probably actually don't enjoy spending
time with those friends and the question
is why are there your friends the we we
don't have the same choice with our
colleagues now if it's on mass you know
you know I like to joke like the only
thing in common with all my failed
relationships is me like if they all get
along but you're the one that doesn't
get along then I would offer that it's
one of two things either you don't
belong in that company or on that team
sometimes you belong in the company but
not that team you know divisions have
sub divisions of companies teams have
subcultures and so sometimes you belong
in the company but in a different part
of the company that could be part of it
or maybe if it's I would I'm not going
to guess that it's toxic but if it's
toxic it could be the just that group of
people but if you're wise are different
you're gonna struggle to get along
because your values are gonna be so so
polar opposite and so what I would do is
find a place but you can find common
values we started this conversation
about the the magic of Corona magic of
Kovac 19 is across the entire planet we
were all having a shared experience and
we all can relate to each other on
entirely new way in other words were all
human beings subjected to the whims of
Mother Nature and so if you truly aren't
getting along with people find common
ground for example I have friends who
have totally different political views
than me totally different and yet I'm so
proud of those friendships because we
could look past politics we can make fun
of each other for our politics we can
have debates about our politics and
discussions about our politics we get
frustrated with each other because of
our politics but we love each other
because we care about each other and
fundamentally the relationship is based
on who we are as human beings and we
view each other's fundamentally good
people who care about us and one of each
other to make to that we feel safe so
find that common human ground as best as
you can and I bet you can find a way to
get along with your colleagues so we'll
do one last one
one less walk away today Brown gritty
women yeah Brown gritty women book club
yes how can we best prepare ourselves
the new normal without knowing what it
is
well let's let's you're a hundred
percent right now one of the things is
this is what we're experiencing is is
normal in the sense that change is a
constant in our world like the way we
live our lives now is is totally
different the way we lived at 20 years
ago like even just 10 years ago reading
some of these the way I speak the
language I choose and start with why cuz
I'm like oh I'd never say those things
now the world is constantly changing it
just is so clear now because it's so
sudden that's what makes it feel that
much more traumatic but remember there's
new technology there's cultural change
that's constantly happening happening
the world order is constantly changing
but those changes attend tend to be slow
so we can adapt slowly and if we don't
adapt we can sort of like get dragged
along like when the internet showed up
some companies grabbed on to net
technology invented new tech new
technologies based on the internet new
companies new ways of seeing the world
and some companies and some industries
is dragged along like television and it
and publishing and some of them have
made up for ground some of the lost
ground and some haven't and so the
question is is not how do we prepare for
new normal because we're trying to
predict the future there the question is
is given the current circumstances right
now how can I bring to life what I
believe in a new way
we know that in person is something
that's going to be delayed for a while
right so the question is is how do we
take advantage of this new this new
world where we are physically distant
how can we create new ways of creating
social closeness while physically
distant I mean you know I talk about it
all the time the importance of human
relationships the importance of social
closeness and again look at what this
book club is this is this isn't just me
talking about start with why bla bla bla
let's have a book club it's just a it's
a foil it's a mechanism yeah the book
club is just a mechanism for us to come
together but most importantly is for you
and your friends to come together to
form the book club it's more important
that you phone book clubs and that
you're hanging out with your friends on
a regular scheduled weekly basis talk
talk about something other than Kovan to
talk about something other than the news
but it's really about togetherness and
you can see what I'm doing I'm trying to
find new ways to advance my cause given
the real circumstances so don't worry
about what the future holds we don't
know
adapt for now and I promise you whatever
new normal is which we cannot predict
you'll be way better equipped to manage
and survive and thrive in that world so
on that I want to say thank you so much
to everyone for coming just a reminder
we're gonna be back on Friday schedule
so Happy Easter Happy Passover happy
national sibling day to everyone for
this weekend which is why we did it on
Saturday but we're gonna be back to our
normal Friday schedule so we've been
doing part three part three of start
with y which is leaders need a following
that should produce some good questions
we're gonna talk gonna get really into
the thick of leadership next week Friday
April 17th back 3 p.m. Eastern Time
Friday April 17th 3 p.m. reminder if
your book club has questions please send
them to
book club at simon Sinek dot-com and we
will also be taking live questions of
course please tell us the name of your
book club it's really fun for us to find
out again book club at Simon Singh Kham
if your book club has questions that we
can get them in advance if you want to
re-watch anything that we've done here
or any of the previous book club
sessions we will put them up on YouTube
and hopefully YouTube live will work
next week we'll try again next week
thank you again for all your patience
thank you for joining take care of
yourselves take care of each other love
you all and see you all next week
[Music]
you